aux 2,37 milliards aujourd'hui pour une
vidéo sur haïti horreur game un petit
jeu flash d'horreur on plaignent en tout
de suite alors jackman talk about the
breaking business or jean jacques a dit
fourrière you could get at least 20
bague 20 sacs alias the fool day kg lac
et de la porte de devant je pense
elle est un gaz donc on est celui qui
amena sing off my que matt zappé la 6e
des logan out so lu ment 1 alors trouve
un sac de monnaie il break tout sexy tu
peux te cacher machin préservent leur
style à ford derrière situation news ma
peine ice to move safe lit et soleil
hier
alors nous apparaissons c'est quoi les
touches d'accord ok donc je vais devoir
tout décalé ouattara fac c'est bon on
est vrai alors j'espère juste qu'on peut
bien ok attend des réglages foireux ok
on est chaud alors on doit trouver donc
des sacs de mandat il ya du vent deux
ans il ya un conflit qui tombent chez
moi c'est parti alors comment on fait
presse aime tout ce matin m waouh
la carte la plus des terriers du monde
prud'homme open ok donc faut entrer en
mode en mode bourrin verser caire auc et
un ballet au yes un sur vingt au [ __ ]
à la porte de chez moi qui souvent vidéo
d'horreur ça ça ne passe pas ça ne passe
jamais bien non ça porte malheur aussi
porte malheur j'aime pas faire ça on va
devoir faire toutes les pièces une par
une je pense pour trouver les 20 bague
alors si ce qu'on a en soi un petit feu
on se pose wesh weezy monnaie non non
non ça va sûrement perdu confiance
bon niveau bruit doha il aurait
peut-être mieux quand même qu un [ __ ]
mais c'est globaux rebelles de merde
tout dû à un sac de monnaie à la lumière
et clignote sans corps aussi affreux
deux sacs de monnaie yes on est à 3 j'ai
passé à quoi le en haut à gauche mais
j'aime pas trop ça en tout cas au [ __ ]
j'ai cru y avait un mec dans les
poubelles
un homme qui ramassait des poubelles yes
4 mais c'est qu'on ait bientôt riches
c'est que nous sommes bien
aux bâtards au mouvement de m inscrire
moeurs bande d'enfoirés
non [ __ ] la bd qui vole comme en
interne on est des vétérans royal et
jean ok ok ou au [ __ ] ans la vache
ferme pas de site et une tête volante
c'était une tête voulons claque dans tes
mains c'est un volant claque dans tes
mains à 600 étoiles ont su tout moment à
la vache aux [ __ ] ok on est dans le
bain c'est bon on est dans le bain on a
tout compris
on a tout compris sandra free on est
parti à cette fois joue je cours je
m'emballe steak
donnez-moi de la monnaie bande de
bâtards amine une porte juste là
d'accord oh là là là il faut se dépêcher
faut se dépêcher
allez hop on rejoint roche on veut juste
prendre mes thunes et rentrer chez nous
parle sans fard être vos merdes modèle
le sac non mais il y en avait un autre
avant merde [ __ ] mon dieu mais quelle
idée de faire des jeux comme ça c'est
n'importe quoi
ouais en scène poêlé wesh eux
[ __ ] moi je laisse pas longtemps je me
casse je me casse
y'a pas de têtes volent autres aux
[ __ ] comment faux speed et mon dieu
il ya des salles creed bâtard je veux
moi c'est bon je n'ai plus peur tout va
mieux on peut y aller on va aller à
droite
wallah une bouteille je me vois la
gueule non non non non non non non non
pas de musique la bonne musique rock
dans un moment pareil en quoique non
plus rater quelque part une tête volant
de quoi c'est pas comme si terme un truc
un truc incroyable mais c'est une [ __ ]
de têtes volantes bordel merde on n'a
jamais vu ça dans l'histoire du jeu
vidéo d'horreur et je tourne en europe 1
why avait un truc là-bas je vous promets
eux
guillemet monnaie kim et moi mais il ya
un col fifty cent
ap le fil des scènes voix
l'escalier le plus glauque du monde mais
parmi nous ce soir
mes chers frères et soeurs nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans la maison la plus
flippante du monde
alléluia shit hockey 8 8 sur 20 c'est
cool il nous en reste plus que douze
jeux sans la tête qui arrive va vous
coûter vais voir ma vie à mes chers
frères et soeurs nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans une merde noire
je voulais témoigner le signal et de ce
que ton ici présents sur mon front
m'empêchant de me faire attaquer par
toutes les espèces vivantes bizarre
[Musique]
oh [ __ ] ok c'est bon se trouvait dans
le bar là le vent ça va oh
lalalalalalalalala montus bordel de
merde et qui a des plantes aussi doux
que ça chez lui [ __ ] de haricots verts
gérant encore fait fort look fans des
combines eisen bien qu'il y ait rien
tout va bien c'est pas comme s'il y
avait une tête voulons qu'ils nous
pourchasser non non pas du tout laplante
bauges sort de leurs petites têtes
volantes n'étant propos plantes il
dottore a fait beaucoup tu veux voir mes
cheveux le jeu tourne en rond mais un
homme en plus de sortir
que dois-je faire brett mais owen franks
je peux plus courir
donc ça doit être ça la stamina ces
genres quand tu peux courir pourtant
fuir des tableaux grand père par exemple
super glauque au un noise aux anneaux a
zoo humain presque tous y
sega a compris ce qui vient de se passer
dit on peut passer par là oh yes oh là
là là là on en a des sacs un [ __ ] j'ai
cru que c'était un ventilateur
les araignées pondéraux merde va devoir
repas et cul ça n'en veut pas au bras ok
donc en laye et rouge en fait je peux
cliquer dessus voir où est la vilaine
têtes volantes
il ya un sous sol on paye dans le sous
sol où il sous sol dis moi oui sous sol
du docu hp dont farid merde dans le
tableau tu sers à rien
on peut aller où on peut les parts ou
pas ici peut-être al-saud yes je sens
bien que l'escalier vers là-bas je sens
bien qu'à une grosse tête bien volante
je crois que là où ça vibre c'est le
verrou là où il ya la tête en fait à
moins que ce soit absolument pas ça et
que je dise que de la merde qui est
totalement envisageable vu la situation
en bon dieu je me suis tellement dessus
bordel de merde
cacolac la vie on va redescendre vélo
sous sol roucou tu veux voir mes jeunes
au hockey tu m'auras jamais je suis
protégé par des hommes non devrait être
interdit par la loi de faire ça bordel
cette fois cette fois c'est la bonne
comme les sacs yes je m'appelle pas dans
la prise pour sortir des styles plus
vite possible
owen
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre
un jeu préféré limite jouer au jeu sur
le xbox live la elsa watz était certes
moins flippant mais c'était plus
agréable
finalement presse aime tous ces maps
mais c'est cette carte ne sert à rien
[ __ ] un bordel quand est-ce qu'ils
comprendront alors je moi ce que je vous
propose c'est qu'on va direct dans mall
annoncé quoi s'attendre à ce que fait
quelle joie que du sable tout à fait
normal mais vous êtes sérieux là c'est
ça c'est un rat c'est cette chose tara
c'est bon ok j'ai vu un sac oh oh j'ai
vu non mais attendez mais c'est sérieux
mais les trois quarts des sacs sont là
dedans comment on peut choper ciel nous
suivent pour faire primer le gaz bon bah
ça explose ça [ __ ] t'es bien moche tu
me fais de moins en moins peur bhp coach
alors c'est parti au camp ni fermoba les
steaks
on descend on y va on y va en mode en
mode corridor c'est absolument rien dire
bon allez ou parce que là on est mort
mais il vient bien viens peut pas tout
et commença par le milieu donc c'est par
là est un placard absolument pas hop la
danse des canards à quai mais my man
legends of rock ap
ici on a normalement ça change à chaque
fois abordé deux pièces on a eu la clé
de basement je passais quoi mais on a
une club armand ce qu'il faut c'est
trouver la salle supercherie de thaler
là où il y avait au moins cinq sacs
dedans pour être prêtes millionnaire
pour avoir de la monnaie pour ce peuple
de tunisie à mettet sérieuse d'être
coupée mais c'est pour le sec
bon faut qu'on change d'endroit faut
qu'on aille en a eu pas de tête donnant
à l'horizon ok je peux pas de barre il
faut que je tourne en bourrique
oui d'accord donc c'est vrai que c'est
la ouate enfin coûté la banque tu peux
pas juste posé quelques pages pour une
douche pas un truc tu sais pas peut-être
à dans le frigo non personne n'aimait
son argent dans le frigo grâce à un peu
une gâchette chou
c'est là en bas ou en bas on va au on
est d'accord
j'aimerais juste ma thune
j'me casse puis depuis quand nikon têtes
coupées a besoin d'argent avant de gérer
un petit note je sais pas pour s'acheter
un corps que je rate les blagues nulles
c'est le site le job toi yes bîmes tarn
samedi aujourd'hui réunis pour fêter
rien du tout super je vous ment toujours
pas quoi servent ces [ __ ] de mesures
annoncées on voit où elle est éternelle
bon nous avons failli à notre mission
c'était très périlleux c'était très
dangereux
j'espère que ça vous a plu moi pas à
light of
[Musique]
oh oh non c'était une toute petite
hausse jusqu'en éclair à l'appel oui il
me sens moi ça va j'ai tant vidéo
l'acheter en train de rage et où tu
sauves à athanor
regardez nous sommes dans le jeu nous
avons passé